economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón dan y buena
noche bienvenida comenzamos en eeuu
donde se estancó la creación de empleos
hola raúl muy buenas noches mire de los
22 millones de empleos que se perdieron
apenas van 8 que todavía no se han
recuperado en la pantalla y la tasa de
desocupación quedó casi intacta en 6,1
por ciento en abril pero muchas empresas
se quejan de que no han podido llenar
sus vacantes las razones varían según el
partido al que se le consulte por un
lado los republicanos culpan al gobierno
por su generosidad con los subsidios
escuchemos
job aiden pide prestados 2 billones de
dólares para un proyecto de ley de
estímulo que paga a los estadounidenses
para que no trabajen lo cual es un
depresor económico no un estímulo ahora
escuchemos que respondió la casa blanca
cuando aprobamos el plan de rescate
quiero recordarles a todos fue diseñado
para ayudarnos en el transcurso de un
año no 60 días un año nunca pensamos que
después de los primeros 50 o 60 días
todo estaría bien y los analistas
independientes por su parte señalan que
muchos están reacios a buscar trabajo
porque temen contagiarse del virus o que
hay padres que no tienen con quién dejar
a sus hijos para ir a trabajar
así dejan ye la cambiamos a ver a
información porque el precio del cobre
alcanzó un nuevo récord histórico y es
una buena noticia para chile que es el
principal productor del mundo el precio
del metal en la bolsa de londres subió
más del 3 por ciento este viernes hasta
los 47 dólares la libra
y se mantiene este precio significará
con el royalty hoy vigente ingresos
adicionales para el estado por casi 10
mil millones de dólares extras que nos
servirán para atender las urgentes
necesidades sociales producto de la
pandemia la noticia raúl llega justo
cuando el congreso debate sin imponer
una realidad del 3% las ventas del cobre
extraído recordemos que hoy existe un
impuesto pero sobre las ganancias de las
mineras el proyecto fue aprobado el
jueves en cámara de diputados y enviado
al senado pero la poderosa industria
minera y el gobierno lo rechazan porque
creen que va a desincentivar la
inversión y vamos ahora a centroamérica
porque las remesas se dispararon en
guatemala pese a la pandemia bueno los
familiares de los emigrantes
guatemaltecos en su mayoría radicados en
eeuu enviaron al país más de 1.200
millones de dólares sólo en abril la
cifra es casi un 80 por ciento mayor a
la de hace un año y el acumulado de los
primeros 4 meses también es 40% más alto
según el banco central las remesas en
guatemala raúl siempre va a tener récord
año tras año desde que se llevan
registros y este dinero es junto con las
exportación
en la principal fuente de divisas del
país y un tema que me gusta mucho mañana
subastará en la botella de vino especial
más cara del mundo raúl una botella una
botella de vino tinto francés llamada
petros 2000 que estuvo junto con otras
11 madurando nada más y nada menos que
en la estación espacial internacional
por 14 meses y volvió a la tierra en
enero las botellas fueron enviadas en
noviembre de 2019 como parte de una
investigación sobre cómo este vino se
adapta a las condiciones del espacio y
estuvieron casi 440 días a 300 millones
de kilómetros de la superficie
y las condiciones de maduración fueron
diferentes a las de las botellas que se
guardaban aquí en la tierra pero no hay
diferencias significativas
quiero decir tanto el petrus espacial
como el petrus terrestre tienen un sabor
fantástico pero resulta que los que
fueron enviados al espacio parecían
evolucionar más rápidamente que la
botella de esas vale normalmente 8 mil
400 dólares pero la casa de subastas
christie's cree que podría subastar la
por desmayes de un millón de dólares
el feliz comprador se va a llevar además
una botella madurada en la tierra pues
para que pueda hacer la comparación
así es daniela y también por supuesto se
lleva una resaca espacial también
indicadores daniela oeste del cerro la
semana con sus principales índices a
punto de registrar nuevos récords con
excepción del tecnológico nasdaq a
europa tuvo ganancias semanales y en
especial la bolsa de madrid que está en
máximos de más de un área también fue
una buena semana para las bolsas
latinoamericanas lideradas por argentina
cuyo presidente está de gira por europa
cifra el día daniel a los 191 mil
vehículos que produjo en abril brasil
el segundo mayor fabricante de américa
latina después de méxico las cifras 47
por ciento menor que en marzo pero
exponencialmente superior al de el año
pasado cuando se ensamblaron apenas
1.800 casos tal y como siempre gracias
por toda la información económica a
ustedes también gracias buena noche
[Música]